er hat es vielleicht mal ein ganz
besonders herzliches willkommen zurück
all den leben zuschauern die über ostern
auf kreuzfahrt waren
deutschland ist wissen sie vielleicht
gar nicht in offizieller kreuzfahrt
weltmeister ja in den letzten zehn
jahren hat sich bei uns die zahl der
kreuzfahrer verdreifacht unter anderem
wahrscheinlich wegen der guten luft ist
in wirklichkeit allerdings gar nicht mal
so gut dass jetzt mehr dreck geht kaum
und das liegt nicht zuletzt am
treibstoff sie tanten ein abfallprodukt
aus der diesel und benzinherstellung
nämlich schweröl
das macht schiffe auf hoher see zu
fahren denn sonder
müllverbrennungsanlagen mein schönstes
ferienerlebnis urlaub auf der sondermüll
verbrennungsanlage ein tränchen
ja man weiß dass was völlig schief läuft
wenn diesel die öko variante ist und
vergessen sie bitte das stuttgarter
neckartor der ware feinstaub hotspot wie
ganz woanders ein highlight des schiffes
liegt direkt hinter den schornsteinen
bei fahrt also genau in der rauchfahne
die eislaufbahn
viele kinder haben spaß beim
schlittschuhlaufen ausgerechnet viele
sind die feinstaubwerte besonders hoch
endlich macht der satz kinder war seit
dem urlaub braun geworden war ich nicht
sind jetzt stimmt endlich ich finde auf
kreuzfahrtschiffen müssten eigentlich so
schock fotos eingeklebt werden wie auch
zigaretten so kreuzfahrten können
tödlich sein oder kreuzfahrten können zu
impotenz führen
ich warte mal impotenz kann zu kreuz
fahren wird ist auch egal ist egal
von beiden
hat der deutschen firmen war sehr
beliebte und kreuzfahrten sind auch so
beliebt weil sie immer preiswerter
werden warum werden die preiswerter
natürlich wie so oft dank ausbeutung ja
sämtliche deutsche hochseekreuzfahrt
kenne fahren unter fremder flagge haben
ausgeflaggt so nennt man das das beet
jetzt so viele vorteile
also jetzt für den reeder nicht für den
mitarbeiter laut vertrag lag sein
basislohn bei knapp 2 dollar die stunde
von den extras musste er wie sah
medizinische eignungstests oder
sozialleistungen in der heimat sein
sogar seine uniform hat er zum teil
selbst gekauft klar weiß ich auch nicht
seine uniform
[Gelächter]